Phi를 여기 이 벡터로
정해볼게요.
유클리드 노름을 계산해 보면 단위 벡터인 것을 알 수 있고,
이 원이 나타내는 것이 바로 그거예요.
실수 성분을 가진 모든
단위 벡터들이에요.
Psi도 여기 이 벡터로 정해볼게요.
이것도 역시 단위 벡터예요.
사실 마이너스 상태인데, 여기서는 그냥 Psi라고 부르고 있어요.
이 두 벡터의 내적을 계산하면,
1 빼기 루트 3을 2 곱하기 루트 2로 나눈 값을 얻어요.
이것은 대략 -1/4이에요.
이 내적의 값은 두 벡터 사이 각도의
코사인과 같은데, 그림에서 볼 수 있어요.
이것은 단위 벡터에 대해 일반적으로
성립하는 것이에요. 두 단위 벡터가 있고 둘 다 실수 성분을 가지면,
두 벡터 사이의 내적은 두 벡터 사이
각도의 코사인과 같아요.
특히, 이 예에서처럼 내적이 0이면,
Psi를 여기 이 상태로 바꾼 경우인데,
두 벡터는 서로
90도 각도에 있어야 해요.
이 모든 것은 어떤 차원의 벡터에도
일반화되는데, 성분이 실수이기만 하면 돼요.
2차원 벡터에만 해당하는 것이 아니에요.
복소수 성분이 있으면 이 그림은
더 이상 맞지 않지만, 그럼에도 불구하고
내적은 보게 되듯이 매우 유용해요.
내적은 매우 중요한 성질들이 있고
지금부터 그 성질 몇 가지를 살펴볼 거예요.
첫 번째는 내적과
유클리드 노름 사이의 관계예요.
어떤 벡터와 자기 자신의 내적을 취하면
유클리드 노름의 제곱을 얻어요.
그래서 벡터의 유클리드 노름은 그 벡터와
자기 자신의 내적의 제곱근과 같다고
말할 수도 있어요.
이것은 우연이 아니에요, 근본적인
관계예요. 여기서 내적의 정의에
복소 켤레가 없었다면
이 공식이 더 이상 성립하지 않을 거고,
유클리드 노름과의 이런 근본적인 관계를 가진
유용한 개념이 되지 못했을 거예요.
유클리드 노름과의 이런 근본적인 관계 말이에요.
다음으로, 내적은 켤레 대칭이에요.
이것은 두 인수의 순서를 바꾸면
내적의 값이 켤레가 된다는 뜻이에요.
이것은 여기 이 등식으로 표현되고,
이 두 식에 대해 왜 그런지 보는 것은 꽤 직관적이에요.
두 가능한 순서에서의 두 벡터의 내적이에요.
내적은 두 번째 인수에 대해 선형이에요.
구체적으로, 벡터 Phi를 두 벡터의
선형 결합으로 정의하면,
Phi 1과 Phi 2의 선형 결합으로 정의하면,
어떤 벡터 Psi와 Phi의 내적은
두 내적의 같은 선형 결합이에요.
이것은 행렬 곱셈이 선형이라는
사실에서 바로 따라와요.
그리고 내적은 첫 번째 인수에 대해
켤레 선형이기도 한데, 여기서 볼 수 있어요.
Psi가 벡터들의 이런
선형 결합이면, Psi와 Phi의
내적을 취할 때,
Bra Psi는 여기 보이는 이 벡터가 되는데,
베타 1과 베타 2의 복소 켤레를 취한 거예요.
그래서 이것이 결과이고, 이것이
켤레 선형성이 의미하는 거예요.
내적의 마지막으로 언급하고 싶은 성질은
엄청나게 유용한 코시-슈바르츠 부등식이에요.
어떤 두 벡터 Psi와 Phi에 대해, 내적의 절댓값은 두 벡터의
유클리드 노름의 곱보다
결코 클 수 없어요. 게다가 부등식의 양변이
같을 수 있는 유일한 경우는 두 벡터가 선형 종속인 경우인데,
이것은 하나가 다른 하나의 스칼라 배와 같다는 뜻이에요.
이것은 사실 모든 수학에서
가장 널리 사용되는 부등식 중 하나이고
양자 정보를 다룰 때 계속해서 사용해요.
그래서 알아두면 매우 좋아요.
다음으로, 내적과 관련된
직교성과 직교정규성의 개념에 대해 이야기할 거예요.
구체적으로, 벡터의 내적이
0과 같은 경우에 대해서요.
정확히 말하면, 두 벡터 Psi와 Phi가
있을 때, 내적이
0과 같으면 직교한다고 말해요.
직교하는 벡터를 직관적으로 생각하는 방법은
서로 직각에 있다는 것이에요.
또는 서로
수직이라고도 할 수 있어요.
사람들은 때때로 직교라는 용어를 서로 전혀
관련이 없는 것들을 지칭할 때 사용해요.
어떤 이슈가 다른 이슈와 직교한다고 말하는 것처럼요.
하지만 그것은 분명히 꽤 비공식적이고
수학적 의미에서 실제로 의미가 있는 건 아니에요. 하지만 직교하는 벡터가 가리키는 방향을 생각하면 연결이 명확해요.
반대 방향이 아니라, 예를 들어 북쪽 대 서쪽처럼 완전히 다른 방향을 가리키는 거예요.
벡터의 집합이 있을 때, 그 집합에서 선택한 어떤 두 서로 다른 벡터가
반드시 서로 직교하면 그 집합을 직교 집합이라고 해요.
이것은 여기 보이는 것처럼 표현할 수 있어요.